you're taking as a starting point that
there is a horse
called consciousness and you're riding
it and the actual riding is very shallow
this is all surface
so let me ask about that horse what's up
with the horse
what what is consciousness
from where does it emerge how like
fundamental is it to the physics of
reality
how fundamental is it to what it means
to be human
and i'm just asking for a friend so that
we can
build it in our artificial intelligence
systems
yeah well it remains to be seen if we
can if
we will build it uh purposefully or just
by accident
this is a major ethical problem
potentially that i mean
my concern here is that we we may in
fact
build artificial intelligence that
passes the turing test
which we begin to treat not only as
super intelligent because it obviously
is and
and demonstrates that but we begin to
treat it as conscious
because it will seem conscious we will
have built it to seem conscious
and unless we understand exactly how
consciousness emerges
from physics we won't actually know
that these systems are conscious right
we'll just you know they may say you
know listen you can't turn me off
because
that's a murder right and we will be
convinced by that
uh dialogue because we will
you know just in the extreme case who
knows when
we'll get there but you know if we build
something like
perfectly humanoid robots that are more
intelligent than we are so we're
basically in you know a westworld-like
situation
there's there's no way we're going to
withhold an attribution of consciousness
from those machines they're just going
to seem they're going to advertise their
consciousness
in every glance and every utterance
but we won't know and we won't know in
some deeper sense that it make
then we can be skeptical of the
consciousness of other people i mean if
someone could roll that back and say
well you don't you know i don't know
that you're conscious or you don't know
that i'm conscious we're just passing
the turing test for one another but
that kind of solipsism isn't justified
you know biologically or i mean we just
anything we
understand about the mind biologically
suggests that you and i
are part of the same you know role that
role
the dice um in terms of
how intelligent and conscious systems
emerged in in the wet wear of
of brains like ours right so it it's not
parsimonious for me to think that i
might be the only conscious person or
even the only conscious primate
you know it's i i would argue it's not
parsimonious to withhold
consciousness from other apes
uh and even other mammals ultimately and
you know once you get beyond the mammals
then my
intuitions are not really clear the
question of
how it emerges is genuinely uncertain
and ultimately the question of whether
it emerges
is still uncertain you can you know it's
not
it's not fashionable to think this but
you can certainly
argue that that consciousness might be a
fundamental principle of matter
that doesn't emerge on the basis of
information processing
even though everything else that we
recognize about ourselves as minds
almost certainly does emerge you know
like an
ability to process language that clearly
is a matter of information processing
because you you can disrupt that process
in in ways that
is um it's just so clear
and um the problem that the confound
with consciousness is that
yes we can seem to interrupt
consciousness and you can give someone
general anesthesia
and then you wake them up and you ask
them what was that like and they say
nothing i don't remember anything but
it's hard to
[Music]
differentiate a mere failure of memory
from a genuine interruption in
consciousness whereas it's not with you
know interrupting speech
you know we know when we've done it and
it's um
it's just obvious that you know you
disrupt the right
neural circuits and you know you've
disrupted speech
so if you have to bet all your money on
one camp or the other would you say
do you earn the side of pan psychism
where consciousness is really
fundamental toward
to all of reality or more on the other
side
which is like it's a nice little side
effect a useful like
hack for us humans to survive where
on that spectrum where do you land when
you think about consciousness
especially from an engineering
perspective i'm truly agnostic on this
point i mean i think i'm you know it's
kind of in
coin toss mode for me i i don't know
and pan psychism is not so
compelling to me again it just seems
unfalsifiable i wouldn't know how the
universe would be
different if pan psychism were true just
to remind people pan psychism is this
idea that
consciousness may be pushed all the way
down into the most fundamental
constituents of matter so there might be
something that's like to be an electron
or
or you know a cork but
then you wouldn't expect anything to be
different at
you know the macro scale or at least i
wouldn't expect anything to be different
um so it may be unfalsifiable it just
might be that reality is not
something we're
as in touch with as we think we are and
that if at its base layer
to kind of break it into mind and matter
as we've done
ontologically is to misconstrue it right
i mean
there's there could be some kind of
neutral monism at the bottom and this
you know this
idea doesn't originate with me this is
this goes all the way back to
bertrand russell and and others you know
100 plus years ago
but i just feel like that the concepts
we're using
to divide consciousness and
and matter it may in fact be part of our
problem
right where the rubber hits the road
psychologically here
are things like well what is death right
like
do we any expectation that we survive
death or any part of us survives death
that really it seems to be the the um
many people's concern here well i tend
to believe just as a small little
tangent
like i'm with ernest becker on this that
there's some
it's interesting to think about death
and consciousness which one
is the chicken which one is the egg
because it feels like death could be the
very thing
like our knowledge of mortality could be
the very thing that creates the
consciousness
yeah well then you're using
consciousness differently than than i
am so for me consciousness is just the
fact
that the lights are on at all that
there's an experiential
quality to anything right so much of the
processing
that's happening in our brains right now
seems certainly seems to be happening in
the in the dark right like
it's not associated with this
qualitative
sense that there's something that's like
to be that part of
the mind doing that mental thing
but for other parts the lights are on
and and we can talk about and whether we
talk about it or not we can
feel directly that
there's something that is like to be us
there's something something seems to be
happening
right and it the seeming in
our case is broken into vision and
hearing and and proprioception and
and um taste and smell
and and thought and emotion and there's
there are the contents of consciousness
that we are familiar with and that we
can
we can have direct access to in any
present moment that when we're
quote conscious and
even if we're confused about them even
if you know we're asleep and dreaming
and we're really inward it's not a lucid
dream we're just totally confused about
our
circumstance what you can't say
is that we're confused about
consciousness like you can't say that
consciousness itself might be an
illusion because
on this account it just means that
things seem any way at all even like if
this you know it seems to me that i'm
seeing a cup
on the table now i could be wrong about
that it could be a hologram i could be
asleep and dreaming i could be
hallucinating
but the seeming part isn't really up for
grabs in terms of
being an illusion it's it's not
something seems to be happening and that
seeming
is the is the context in which every
other thing
we can notice about ourselves can be
noticed and then
it's also the context in which certain
illusions can be
cut through because we're not we can be
wrong about what it's like to be us and
we can
uh i'm not saying we're incorrigible
with respect to
our claims about the nature of our
experience but
for instance this you know many people
feel like they have a self and they feel
like it has free will
and you know i'm quite sure at this
point that they're wrong about that and
that you can
you can cut through those experiences
and then things seem a different way
right so it's not that
it's not that things don't there aren't
discoveries to be made there and and
assumptions to be overturned but
um this kind of consciousness
is something that i would think it
doesn't just come online
when we get language it doesn't just
come online when we form a concept of
death or the the finiteness of life
it doesn't it doesn't require a sense of
self right so it doesn't it it's
it's prior to a differentiating self and
other
and i wouldn't even think it's
necessarily
limited to people i mean i do think
probably any
mammal has this but certainly if you're
going to if you're going to
presuppose that something about our
brains
is producing this right and that's a
very
safe assumption even though it we can't
even you can argue the jury is still out
to some degree
then it's very hard to draw a principled
line between us and chimps
you know or chimps and and rats even in
the end
given the underlying neural uh
similarities so
um and i i don't know you know
phylogenetically i don't know how far
back to push that you know it's there
people you know think
single cells might be conscious or that
you know flies are certainly conscious
they've got
something like thousand neurons in their
brains and it says
it's just that's a there's a lot going
on even in a fly
right uh but i i don't have intuitions
about that
but it's not in your sense an illusion
you can cut through i mean
to push back the alternative version
could be
it is an illusion constructed by
just by humans i'm not sure i believe
this but it
and part of me hopes this is true
because it makes it easier to engineer
is that humans are able to contemplate
their mortality
and that contemplation in itself creates
consciousness
that like the the rich lights on
experience so the lights don't actually
even turn on
in the way that you're describing until
after birth
in that construction so it's do you
think it's possible that that is the
case that it is a
sort of construct of the way we deal
almost like a social tool to deal with
the reality of the world
the social interaction with other humans
or yeah because you're saying the
complete opposite which is it's like
fundamental to to signal cell
organisms and trees and and and so on
right well yes i i don't i don't know
how
far down to push it i don't have
intuitions that single cells are likely
to be conscious but
uh but they might be i just again i
could be unfalsifiable
um but as far as babies not being
conscious or like you're not you don't
become conscious until you can
recognize yourself in a mirror or you
have a conversation or treat other
people first of all babies treat other
people as others
far earlier than we have
traditionally given them credit for and
they certainly do it before they they
have
language right so it's it's like it's
got to perceive language
uh to some degree and you can
interrogate this for yourself
because you can put yourself in various
states that are
rather obviously not linguistic you know
meditation allows you to do this you can
certainly do it with psychedelics where
it's just
your capacity for language has been
obliterated
and yet you're all too conscious in fact
i think you could make a stronger
argument for
things running the other way that
there's something about
language and and conceptual thought that
is
eliminative of conscious experience that
that we're we are potentially much more
conscious
of data sense data and everything else
than we tend to be
and we have trimmed it down based on
how how we have um acquired concepts and
so like
when i walk into a room like this i know
i'm walking into a room
i have certain expectations of what is
in a room you know
i would be very surprised to see you
know wild animals in here or a waterfall
or you know things i'm not expecting
but i can know i'm not expecting them or
i'm expecting their absence because
of my capacity to be surprised once i
walk into a room and i see a you know
a live gorilla or whatever so
there's there's structure there that we
have put in place based on all of our
conceptual
learning and language and and language
learning
and it causes us not to
one of the things that happens when you
take psychedelics and you just look as
though for the first time
at anything it becomes
incredibly overloaded with uh it can
become overloaded with meaning
and and uh
just the the torrents of sense data that
are coming in
in even the most ordinary circumstances
can become overwhelming for people and
it that tends to just
obliterate one's capacity to capture
any of it linguistically and as you're
coming down right
have you done psychedelics you've ever
done acid or not acid
mushroom and that's it
and also edibles but that's that there
are some psychedelic properties to them
but right
but yeah mushrooms uh several times and
always had an incredible experience
it it exactly the kind of experience
you're referring to which is
if it's true that language constrains
our experience it felt like i was
removing some of the constraints
right because even just the most basic
things were beautiful in a way that
i wasn't able to appreciate previously
like trees and nature and so on
yeah and the the experience of coming
down
is an exp is an experience of
encountering the futility of of
capturing
what you just saw a moment ago in words
right like especially if you have any
part of your
your self-concept and your your ego
program is to be able to capture things
in words and if you're a writer or
you know a poet or a scientist or
someone who wants to just
encapsulate the profundity of what just
happened
the the
total fatuousness of that enterprise
when you really have got when you have
taken a
you know a whopping dose of psychedelics
and you begin to
even gesture at
cat describing it to yourself you know
so that you could describe it to others
it's just it's like trying to you know
thread a needle using your elbows i mean
it's like you're you're trying something
they can't it's like
the mere gesture proves it's
impossibility
uh and it's um
so yeah so that i mean that for me that
that suggests just
empirically on the first person side
that it's possible to put yourself in
a condition where it's clearly not about
language uh structuring your experience
and you're having much more experience
than you you
tend to so the primacy of them language
is primary for
some things but
it's certainly primary for certain kinds
of concepts and certain kinds of
semantic understandings of of the world
but
it's uh it's clearly more to mind than
than the conversation we're having with
ourselves or that we can have with
others
you